it's best practice to provide resources
for supporting all devices but sometimes
it might seem like you need to make a
trade-off between supporting devices and
a small a B K now if you're not using
multi FK supporting different screen
densities CPU architectures and language
could account for a pretty big chunk of
your apps apk size
that's why we've introduced a new
publishing format called the Android app
bundle it'll mean smaller downloads for
your audience and easier artifact
management in the Play console for you
an app bundle is a single comprehensive
build artifact that you upload to Google
Play instead of an apk compared to multi
apk an app bundle delivers smaller apps
to users and is simpler to manage
because it's only one build artifact
when Google Play has your app bundle it
uses a new process for delivering apk is
called dynamic delivery put simply it
only sends the portions of your app that
each user needs now just using the new
app bundle format will automatically
give your users apks with obli P
language screen density and ABI
resources that they require and it
requires no code refactoring from you
building an app bundle is just a matter
of selecting the right build output when
using Android studio here you'll see the
option to generate a signed app bundle
select building a bundle instead of an
apk provide your key choose the
destination folder and you're done
you'll then have your shiny new app
bundle you'll also need to enroll in
Google Play app signing in the Play
console Google Play is essentially
generating optimized apks for your users
so you need to give it the ability to
sign those apks for you app bundles are
supported by Google Play right now the
technology that playe uses to generate
apks from the bundle is open-source so
in the future your app bundle will work
with other app stores that enable
support bundles work for all devices
devices running lollipop and higher get
the greatest size benefit from dynamic
delivery but pre lollipop devices will
still get a multi apk style apk which is
automatically generated by Google Play
from your app bundle let's go ahead and
take a closer look at how Google Play
actually uses this bundle what dynamic
delivery is doing and how users get
their apks in the past you'd upload an
apk and then play would then serve that
same apk when you upload an app bundle
Google Play takes that bundle and splits
it into multiple smaller apks known as
split apks the part of the app which is
always downloaded is placed into a split
apk called the base apk when using a
bundle plate automatically makes split
apks for resources assets and native
libraries these resource specific split
apks are called configuration apks let's
take a look at an example I'm an
english-speaking user on a pixel 2 XL
with 560 dpi resolution right I got an
arm 64 processor if I install your app
dynamic delivery will find just the
split apks that I specifically need
these split apks will be delivered down
to compatible devices and behave like a
single customized apk that's optimized
for my device for earlier devices
dynamic delivery will send out a multi
apk with resource appropriate ABI and
density resources with the introduction
of the Android app bundle and dynamic
delivery we're allowing for
automatically smaller apps at a smoother
deployment process in addition the app
bundle format also introduces dynamic
features released a beta dynamic
features allow you to modular as
specific features and then deliver them
to your users on demand for more
information check out the links below if
you're curious about bundle afire your
app the best place to get started is gqo
android app bundle happy coding
[Music]